what is that so that is Tottenham cake
why Tottenham because it was it came
from Tottenham originally
so that's the only trophy they won
[Music]
hi guys it's Patrice Evra I am here on
snack Wars on sport Bible and today
we're doing UK versus France
[Music]
garlic
because you bring me back on my
childhood
Pico
I hate pickles
so this is like you already lose like I
don't even have to test it
oh oh my God
oh
they didn't even look alive like
ah mama
it's strong what is so strong wait wait
a minute you know when you're at the
beginning it's no good
but then it start like you know what
wait let me respect the people way
nobody's so weird
so you're playing me huh okay my little
pickle
I think it's the combination maybe with
the cheese and the pick I mean like the
piglets I won't eat it just himself but
with the cheese I promise you that the
taste is actually good
I'm eating all of it
I know I love garlic bro
because to be honest it's a long time I
didn't know it's a person so
now
yeah I'm sorry
just going to have a bad breath after
your show so thank you very much because
I've got other meeting so thank you very
much
[Applause]
yeah
Mosa
[Laughter]
what is that so that is Tottenham cake
why Tottenham because it was it came
from Tottenham originally
so that's the only trophy they won
guys by the way I love my Tottenham fan
I promise you guys I always say if I
didn't play for United if I had to to
play for a team in in England we'll be
Tottenham did you ever have a chance to
play for Tottenham during the playing um
I think they were interested they were
interested in them before you know I
joined uh also man united he was like
you know I think he was Tottenham
Liverpool
Man United and Inter Milan in Italy
after of course I picked Man United and
the rest is just his story this is what
is this
it's like a rugby bowl or whatever this
is not a croissant you see that that's
the problem like French people you need
to respect the crusher you need to cook
it like with love and this is being like
frozen or whatever this is not a
croissant and you know French people we
really like
but we love our croissant
and no
no no
[Music]
I did on purpose seriously
so let's see
of course I'm gonna pick the Tottenham
cake
because
I look sweet
strawberry and it tastes very good but
this is not a croissant next time please
bring a real croissant
you know you're gonna be maybe lucky
because as a freshman I used to never
like orange you know oh really yeah the
only things is the bottle we like the
bottle the shape or whatever anyone bro
but look look at the difference look at
the the the the French style and the
English style so that's actually the
national drink of Scotland
okay so it's crumble trying anyway it
looked like a beer
this look romantic this looks sexy she
wanna look at it even kiss it
you know so even if the test is no good
I'm maybe going to pick the Orangina so
yes those crazy drink
I already
oh
hello excuse me
pardon wait a minute wait a minute
okay my Scottish people
you got me on this one
oh wait wait a minute wait a minute
yeah I'm honest I have to be honest I
will give to her
and bro I don't know you call it yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay okay now you want France to win
good this is jafake never see it even
the package but again guys again you see
the presentation you see this is like
cute this is just a box like black
just get on your face you open it
I mean I know they are snacks but you
see oh
hold on hold on
because I love chocolate so
[Music]
like they say don't judge the book by
its cover
but please don't tell me in the middle
you have like some you know Jam like I
think you're gonna have to find out
Patrice because I hate it
yeah that's the one I don't like
I will force myself to eat that
um
I think this one was an easy easy win to
be honest so the macaron gets the point
but it's what a silly question
you want me to start speaking French
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is already a win for caramba you
know what because I'm not a big fan of
licorice let me try this one too
yeah yeah I know this one yeah
not a big farm
ER
the best part of karamba is uh
we always we call it joke of karamba
because before I don't know if they
still do it I will check because it's a
really long time I didn't eat karamba
and thank you for reminding me I'm
getting really old thank you for that
normally the caramba you open it and in
the pack you have always like a joke
okay it's like like silly joke I will
translate it's a total mom she get ready
his son and saying you're gonna be uh
you're gonna be late for school so quick
quick because you're gonna be late and
you're gonna miss the end the bus uh
coming in four hours
you see that's what I mean so let's
start right in my wheelhouse
so yeah that way
so you know I remember caramba because
we love that those little you know joke
and yeah
oh
guys did you put those garamba in the
freezer
is really hard to eat so
this is an easy win I'm sorry just about
the joke is a good joke
France wins yay
yes
anyone that you particularly had like
really tough days against
a check
no
Joe Hart
we scored against him